all the gear
no idea all for like most
great ideas is it upside down
great ideas no gear
my name is dan mace and i'm a film
director
endless problems i specialize in
directing tv commercials like
over the next few days i'm going to
create an app
[Music]
an ad with the exact same idea the same
crew
lighting props production team
everything
but one with a hundred dollar camera
actually think it was cheaper than a
hundred dollars this thing's ridiculous
it's made to look like a cannon same
font and the other
with a one million dollar camera this
thing is really heavy and uh
i'm gonna play back both ads one shot on
this
[Music]
how do i play that
and the other shot on this very
expensive rig
[Music]
and then you be the judge to see if you
can even tell
which one was shot on which one if you
get it right
there will be a prize
but there will be a prize there will be
a prize this would be the prize
i started to ideate with a few ice cream
sticks and other bits and bobs from
around my factory
because attainability here is the most
important
what would be the least expensive
non-brand
addy ad item or service i could make
this spot about with no extra cast
members
and the least amount of pre-production
as i only had
a few days to get this done i came up
with something pretty creative
i think that's super complex
very simply i first secured the best
people from
big big expensive camera toy
manufacturers and operators called
big bird a huge favor for my friends at
panavision
quick interjection here for full
transparency and all the tecus out there
this camera body itself
isn't one million dollars well you can't
actually purchase it but other tech
specialists have rated it somewhere
around the 250
000 mark just as the body alone along
with a set of fizer lenses which are
highly rare come to about 150 000
and then with all the gear to make the
camera work and correctly
comes well over seven hundred thousand
dollars he has an actual printout of the
gear list from panavision so if you want
to go do your background checking
uh go ahead then the hundred dollar
camera isn't actually a hundred dollars
without shipping it's only around forty
dollars but because of a few
modifications we had to do
to get it production worthy we'll settle
at 100
us dollars i think it's fair back to the
crew
lighting team a dop which is a fancy way
of saying cameraman
pixel pulse image specialists art
departments
everyone always messages me saying to
make films with me
and this is audience every single time
and my bank card but now to take this
idea and get it written
in order to create the greatest non-ad
ad the world has ever seen
[Music]
whoa wait wait this isn't a car ad
that's not even my car
it's jared who shot the behind the
scenes girlfriend's car
where was i oh [ __ ] we're in my mind
okay uh so
i guess we can take this thing for a
spin anywhere then i'm thinking
somewhere majestic the amazon perhaps
or polo opposite like tokyo drifting
around the pyramid of diesel
oh no epic like like summiting mount
kenya a snowfall
[Music]
who am i kidding that's better yeah a
car wearing a car has a hat
and then bam impact
a slow motion walk while i talk about
the blue merch looking fly here
an invisible cut out from black to
reveal the notion that
no matter how big or small the idea
forget the gear it's your action that
creates it all
[Music]
and then boom powerful quote
spoiler alert that non-ad ad you just
watched was all shot
on this camera called camera wait wait
before you go on ebay or amazon
that's a lie it's blatant horrible
terrible eye
uh i can't endorse a product like this
that's supposed to be the base plate
wait how do i roll on this thing really
it also only shoots 720p
at 4x3 and the quality is
atrocious but don't lose faith in this
toy made for very very small children
because
i put my ego aside and begged my fellow
comrades
and recreated that entire non-ad ad and
even after the pain and the effort of
really really trying my utmost best to
just draw quality out of this toy i'm
still a firm believer that
idea comes before gear and hey who knows
if you still think that the quality
looks the same i would suggest going and
visiting your local optometrist
i'm gonna go ahead and embarrassingly
press play
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
alright gaps is the only person i was
brave enough to show that to
opinion honest opinion brilliant really
unbelievable
don't just say that baby it was so so
great
one of your films that i was most
excited to see come to life and i loved
seeing the two different cameras
you get the the concept yes it's like
you
and everyday life driving and or going
in search in search of a great idea
until you hit a wall and realize that it
was
right in front of you all along you got
that from the piece
it's you of course you didn't read my
script you didn't send it to me i didn't
i really didn't think that that would
translate
gabs's opinion matters most
obviously i went to the extreme here by
using the shittiest [ __ ]
camera in the world i do get that that's
completely extreme and the one you know
there's no comparison between the two
cameras but it's not about that it's
about starting this conversation
about gear versus idea i think we live
in a world where
we all want the best tech and we're
forgetting about the ideas
how do you feel about that
gab's is still on like an iphone one
[ __ ] why did i actually ask your opinion
baby
as i was saying discussion so let's
start a conversation in the comment
section below tomorrow i'm going to
upload a video
with because there's just so much
footage and so many technicalities that
went into making this video
and i really like to answer those
questions and just show a lot more of
behind the scenes
i just wanted to cap this one keep it
short you know
to the point straight to the point and
on that note if it's your first time
here
please subscribe if it's your second or
third time you still haven't subscribed
you know it's time to subscribe and
put on your notifications bowl and then
smack that
like button other than that don't forget
you're awesome brew
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
beginners